so now we're in a fancy little spot we
can create a physics engine update it
delete objects from it add bodies to it
entities in the environment can add
their own physics bodies and of course
update them over time and now we get to
the final part of the equation how we
actually drive the entire simulation
from our game engine object this is a
little bit easier than you think inside
of our game engine class we first define
the number of physics updates that we
want per frame now remember before we
were talking about the number of physics
loops steps we would like to occur
inside of a frame to move our world
forward in the game engine setup
function we actually need to call an
initializer on our global physics engine
class and also inside of the game
engines update function we need to
actually call the physics engine update
method so that it'll do a step process
on all the world objects